his morning began in North London
talking about maths
we simply cannot allow poor numeracy to
cost our economy tens of billions a year
but now the PM facing questions about
whether his own declarations add up do
you have any questions on things that
are not related to maths
back in Westminster they had plenty
today the Parliamentary standards
Watchdog announcing a probe into the
Prime Minister over whether he breached
rules when declaring his links to a
childcare firm that his wife invests in
when asked about it in Parliament just
weeks ago
wishes to declare and respect of that no
I mean all my all my disclosures are
declared in the normal in the normal way
the PM not disclosing to MPS that his
wife held shares in koru kids when they
quizzed him about increased funding for
child care from which that company could
benefit
but he had declared the interest to the
cabinet office as required a point he
later clarified in a letter to the
committee Rishi sunak said I know that
there has been some major coverage
relating to the minority State my wife
has in relation to the company koru kids
I was being asked questions by the
committee in my capacity as PM I would
like to clarify for the Parliamentary
record that this interest has rightly
been declared to the cabinet office but
the question is whether the PM should
have told MPS when asked the code of
conduct states that members must always
be open and Frank in declaring any
relevant interest in any proceeding of
the house or its committees
will the minister set out why she
considered it necessary to incentivize
child minders to sign up with agencies
and what conversations she and the
secretary of state had with the Prime
Minister and the agency in which his
wife is a shareholder prior to the
budget
um I know that the number 10 team are
collaborating with the commissioner to
establish facts and show that everything
has been transparently declared number
10 say that there's no case to answer
that the Prime Minister did declare his
wife's financial interest in the correct
manner to the cabinet office in a
perplexed by this probe but it is
nevertheless uncomfortable for a prime
minister to be under investigation when
he promised on the steps of Downing
Street but months ago a government of
Integrity professionalism and
accountability and it gives his
political opponents an opportunity to
accuse him of dodging scrutiny just
weeks away from a set of critical local
elections
a PM who wanted to show voters he was a
break from the past but his wife's
wealth again becoming an issue the
question is whether the public will care
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster